all right good humans of the Internet
I believe I'm live and I believe we
still have an Internet
that's at least semi functioning
although Netflix has been running pretty
slow and our internet around here has
been pretty wacky even though we've got
you know like the highest level possible
business internet that you can have all
right there's obviously a ton to talk
about as you can see I'm doing this
today from my computer so I'm I'm in the
studio here we've got the fancy lights
going on and I'm in the studio but I'm
my computer because obviously right now
we're just trying to limit the amount of
people that are in the house in my house
and our offices are here and we have
people come going all the time obviously
not the best time to be doing that
perhaps the worst time to be doing that
so our director matt is working remotely
today we just actually hired a new
associate producer today actually
started today we hired him about a month
ago
welcome aboard Michael who is working
remotely and Helen and Alexis and David
and everyone else and Talia everyone's
working remotely today obviously so I'm
just doing this with the with the webcam
okay so before I do anything else if for
those of you that are following me on
social media you know that I adopted a
new dog we adopted a new dog couple days
ago I'm sure most of you know that our
previous dog Emma passed away last month
it's about five weeks ago now she lived
to 16 had an absolutely wonderful life
we weren't ready to get a new dog but
then and also I was going to be on tour
which now the tour is very up in the air
obviously because of all this
everything's up in the air
anyway we weren't gonna get a new dog
because tour and just we wanted to take
a little break and like get life and
order and we're working on some other
things and blah blah blah and also you
just need some time I think between
these things but anyway a few days ago I
saw that they were closing all the
shelters in Los Angeles and I ran to our
local shelter and our local shelter here
is a non kill shelter it's pretty small
they're really wonderful and they had
just rescued six dogs that we're gonna
be put down that day and they had
arrived 20 minutes before I walked in I
basically had to like fight my
way in because they weren't even letting
people in and blah blah blah and I saw
this one dog in the back and I was like
oh my god what's the deal and he was
about to be put down so I want to
introduce you all Clyde Clyde come on in
man
Clyde let's go let's go Oh first time in
the studio buddy what's up man so this
is Clyde everybody
hey Clyde is one year old he is
extremely excited cried because of the
studio first time in a studio so I know
you want to see Clyde not me now
so there's Clyde I'll just tell you
Clyde's story real quick that I'll show
you more right and then we'll take your
questions and a hold by each other stuff
so Clyde's one year one year old he was
found in Riverside California
he actually had he was with a family at
least for a portion although they found
him on the street because he is
house-trained and Clyde don't eat any of
the equipment please we're still working
on some of that stuff no chewing on
wires
these are serious things we got here
he's house trained he knows how to sit
and all that but they found him on the
street and he had been in a band and
he's he's pretty thin so we're gonna
we're gonna fatten him up a little bit
and and he's got a scar when he comes
back over I'll show you he's got a
really intense scar right in the middle
of his head and like two other tiny ones
over here almost like a cigarette scar
and I can see he's a little skittish
around loud noises so I have a feeling
he was probably it looks like I don't
know if it was a cigarette scar or
whatever but like I think he's he's
lived through some stuff Clyde get in
here hi what you doing what you doing
there we go
so you can see the scar right there
anyway he's extremely happy and we're
thrilled obviously that we could we
could save a pup and and I you know I
know a bunch of you actually I tweeted
something out about this and a whole
bunch of you guys have been you know
fostering or adopting cats and dogs and
rabbits and all kinds of stuff which is
which is just great because you know
there's a human cost here there's an
animal cost these people working at the
shelters are busting their ass and
they're mostly volunteers so we're gonna
make a nice donation over there
and yeah so we've got a new member of
the family and also a whole many of you
have noticed he looks bizarrely like
Emma yeah which is a total coincidence
so I think he's some sort of pit
maybe lab Basenji or red healer they
call him Australian Cattle Dog mix but
he's he's just great and what great
moment and and his balls just got
snipped so they are shriveling up as we
speak and and anyway it's it's a crazy
time right now like at write like in the
midst of all of this craziness which
obviously we'll talk about a little bit
that was the other thing that just kind
of pushed me to do this I was like these
dogs are these dogs are gonna die you
know these these shelters are overloaded
and everything else and and here we are
so we're expanding a little bit around
here at the roof and reporter hey Claude
what's going on yeah there we go there
we go I show them your good teeth it's
got the most beautiful white teeth I've
ever seen you should be in a commercial
okay so Clyde's gonna hang out there oh
by the way I know it's gonna show up
backwards because these these webcams
are a little bizarre but we have the
first hard copies of my book
don't burn this book thinking for
yourself in an age of unreason which as
of a few days ago so our publisher
penguin Random House which is really the
the big boy in the space you know
they're delaying a lot of books they're
canceling some stuff so we had a massive
call with all the top people and the
publicists and the publisher and the
blah blah blah and everybody and we are
not delaying my book if anything I was
trying to push it out early because so
many of you guys are asking you know how
do I want a book to read or I just want
something new to do so I tried to get it
earlier we can't do it earlier but it
will be out on April 28th come hell or
high water and we also got some great
news which is a little bittersweet at
the moment which is that we're gonna be
placed the book is going to be placed at
the front table of all the Barnes &
Noble which is awesome except we just
don't know if any of the stores are
gonna be open so anyway it's like it's
like we're all dealing with all this
like conflicting like inspiring stuff
and then sort of crazy stuff alright
glad I'll see you later all right
Clyde's out of here it's just us guys
anyway if you want to if you want to
preorder the book
you can go to dumper in this book
dot-com and and you know if for anyone I
wasn't going to do this but we're all
trapped at home right so for anyone that
buys the book during this live stream
while I'm live we'll send you a book
plate I'll sign it and send it to you
all you have to do is forward your
receipt so you can buy it at Amazon or
Barnes and noble.com or your local book
retail or whatever it is if you buy the
book during this thing during this live
stream I'll sign a book plate for you
we'll send that out to you you can slap
it on the book and and there you go
anyway so this is crazy right we are we
are crazy I am here in Los Angeles we're
basically under lockdown right like
you're really not allowed to leave your
house you know you can take a walk and
you can walk your dog and by the way
Africa having a new young pup after
having a 16 year old dog you know with
cancer and arthritis and everything out
the girl I mean this guy he is a
freaking speed demon but it's been nice
actually just taking some walks because
at least from 6 feet away you can see
your neighbors and everyone's kind of
going through the same thing and we're
all kind of looking at each other you
know cuz there anything I can do to help
you know it's just everyone's got this
kind of dazed look in their eyes like I
was at the supermarket a couple days ago
you know we've been we've been pretty
good around here about preparing in
advance and we got a lot of canned stuff
and box stuff and we froze some stuff
and got an extra freezer and even though
it's LA and I very small property along
the along the side of the house like two
years ago a long weekend we just built
some planters and we're planting
tomatoes and cucumbers and some lettuce
and stuff like that and it's like all of
these things seem particularly valuable
right now right like it's like we've all
suddenly become Preppers you know like
all the people that the media and
everybody mocked all this time are
starting to be a little bit ahead of the
curve and I'm actually noticing that
online just from some of the accounts
that I thought of as more fringe counts
fringe accounts are suddenly feeling a
little more ahead of the curve and a
little more relevant I'm also noticing
like a certain amount of people that I
thought were really relevant you know
like two years ago just if you're just
fighting over the same old political
nonsense right now like how relevant is
that utterly irrelevant like there
a new paradigm emerging right now and we
all can see it and if you're out there
screaming though all the Democrats this
or all the Republicans this or just
looking at everything in that old lens
as we are in truly unchartered territory
here I'm just not that interested in you
and you know I'm pretty good you know I
try to follow people on social media of
all walks of life and all different
political persuasions and people that I
agree with and disagree with and all
that and just in Alaska days I actually
did have to unfollow a couple accounts
that are just bashing us with the same
old partisan politics and I would
actually recommend that you do this same
glad making a return I'll Club is coming
back I'm being told that we're a little
we're a little blurry and pixelated
right now
you know our you know I think the
internet right now and maybe
particularly in Los Angeles because
we're one of the places under this kind
of full quarantine
maybe our internet is just out of whack
we could do a speed check maybe it's
cousin Clyde Clyde you move it too fast
he returned you know what if I try not
to move the camera for a little bit and
I'll try not to talk with my hands too
much that's a little hard for me because
maybe that'll allow this thing to reset
but but I'm sorry about the quality I
think we're all dealing with some some
weird stuff right now
anyway I was saying I actually did
unfollow a couple accounts one of them
even someone that's been on the show
just cuz if you're just putting out the
same old stuff and you're just trying to
get everybody to fight right now like
that's not what this is about
we're in a were at a time for we're at a
time for a lover he's not for fighters
right now you know you know if you check
my Twitter actually you know I sent out
a couple tweets this morning like if
you're trying to look for a job let's
let's try to help each other if you've
got a job you know let's try to help you
try there what can we do to help each
other right now I think is key my my
grandmother her in-laws up in Jersey and
we had ordered her a whole bunch of
stuff on Amazon and some other places
too you know food and supplies and
things like a week and a half ago and
she didn't tell us that they didn't
arrive and she was really running low on
stuff yesterday
and then my my good buddy John who's
been my best friend since I'm four years
old I met him the first day I remember
meeting him the first day of
kindergarten in 1981 or 1988 II he and
his girlfriend he's in Jersey and he
took a drive and he dropped off stuff
for my grandmother-in-law I left it
outside the house they got to wave
through the window and that was it I
mean what a crazy time but I but I think
there's an opportunity here for this to
bring out the best in all of us and I'm
really trying I'm trying not to get into
the fights I'm trying to not overload
everybody you know one of the things
that I think put the the IDW the
intellectual darkweb on the map over the
last couple years is that it was very
obvious to a certain amount of us I
think most of you guys that watch this
or that listen to this it was pretty
obvious to you that our sense making
ability in this country was really
breaking down and it was breaking down
at so many levels right like politicians
weren't really making sense or talking
about the right issues the media and CNN
and the New York Times and these these
trusted sources were all kind of
breaking down and then a couple voices
you know came out of nowhere
I would say most most specifically
Jordan Peterson was like the the
pinnacle of it but Sam Harris
so know and a whole bunch of other
people and that really were completely
diverse politically I always find it
funny you know people will say oh that
whole IDW crew whatever it is it's like
you guys you're all you all think the
same things and it's like literally sam
harris and ben shapiro think the
opposite on virtually everything right
from taxes to religion to pretty
opposite and I happen to like both
anyway I think why that emerged and why
you guys that watch these things on
YouTube and listen to podcast everything
else why you guys were ahead of the game
on this was because while they were out
there the mainstream media was just out
there not making sense having the same
old fights not addressing the real
issues buying inside entity politics and
all thing you guys were finding
something that was much more real and I
hear that from people all the time
actually the other day I was I was at
our local liquor store here and they're
not you can't go in anymore you have to
place an order and then they
email you when your order is ready and
then you can go and they're letting in
literally one person at a time so it was
a massive line outside and I'm waiting
on line and this guy walks out he's got
two big jugs of whiskey and he looks at
me because Dave keep doing what you're
doing man we need ya and then all these
other people looked at me like I'm like
I'm I don't know what I am like I'm a
doctor or something like no no no guys
just babble on for a living
hey how you doing so so yeah we're in
weird times and I and I'm really gonna
try to help unite people right now I am
NOT gonna pretend that I have all the
answers cuz I don't and anyone
pretending that they have all the
answers that they know exactly what's
gonna happen with the coronavirus and
they know exactly how it's gonna
transmit or they know exactly what the
government should do or they know the
exact thing related to timing or or the
economic fallout or any of those things
it can't eat chapstick or we're working
on we're working on some behavior stuff
so he lived on the streets for a while
so you know he said he's a scrapper this
guy anyway so I'm really gonna try to do
my best to to not add to the madness
right now make a little sense of this by
the way speaking of that one thing that
I think has actually been really cool is
that I think what what is happening on
the internet right now is that it's
becoming very obvious something that
I've been talking about for quite some
time like that that small is the new big
that local communities are the new big
that you should care much more what
happens in your local community than
what's happening you know at the
national level now not not completely
but think about you have much more
control about what your local community
and what the people on your street are
doing and all of that and especially at
a time like this when we're all trapped
in our houses it's good to know your
neighbors you know I mean like I've
actually been making a point and it's a
lot easier when you have a dog of saying
hello to neighbors I try to do it in
general but like saying hello to
neighbors and I traded my phone number
with an older woman yesterday if she
needed anything and she's got she's
actually got a an older dog that she
thinks she may have to put down in midst
of this which is which is horrific of
course but I really do think that is
going to be the new big which is really
why I started locals and we've
built out something really nice said the
Reuben report community so I welcome all
of you guys to jump over there and see
what we're doing yesterday we did a
movie afternoon it's the second one we
did last Sunday we watched the movie
contact and then we did a big group zoom
together as many people as can get in
there and we see everybody at once and
we all talked about it and everything
and it's really fun and cool and there's
no trolls and box because it does cost a
couple bucks to get in which I just have
to do because it keeps out all of the
all of the haters and all that nonsense
and I want things to feel secure that
has nothing to do with free speech right
because it's like I believe in free
speech on the street but I don't welcome
everybody into my house to tell me that
I'm a dick
except on Twitter anyway we did that and
then yesterday we watched idiocracy and
we did a big group chat and there were
people there was a lovely woman who's a
new immigrant to America or she's
waiting for her green card now but she's
been here for a while from Iran we were
chatting with Lucia in Argentina who was
just wonderful young young lady in
Argentina who is telling us how she's
like boy you Americans I'm seeing you
guys all freaked out about not having
toilet paper and and paper towels and
whatever but it's being restocked and
you should live here where it's always
much harder to get putting a little
stuff into perspective from Americans
but talk to people in Canada and just
all over America obviously and what
happened just like a great communication
thing I think one thing we're gonna do
or try to do it maybe one night this
week is like a dinner with Dave kind of
thing so we're gonna post a recipe
probably something very simple like a
spaghetti and meatballs or meat sauce
kind of thing that anyone can do and
crack open a jar it's tomato sauce if
you don't want to you know cook too much
or whatever you don't have the exact
right supplies and then we'll just set a
computer at the table and we'll have
some wine together and do it over zoom
which by the way I hope one of the
things you guys are doing right now in
this craziness is he's trying to connect
with family as they're dealing with all
this too so we did we did a dinner on
Friday night here with my parents and my
sister and her family are now at my
folks in the suburbs they wanted to get
out of New York City which I can only
imagine how tense it would be in New
York City right now and if you're in big
buildings with elevators and all these
people you don't know and everything
else like the ability to stay clean and
everything so we just sat computer their
table computer at our table and we have
I stand her together we did it with my
with my brother and his family in the
burbs couple days ago we did it with
with David's grandma and his family so
try to keep connecting with people I
know I'm not telling you anything that's
you know rocket science here guys but I
think I think the important thing is you
know as we for now if we can't get
together and face-to-face meetings we've
got to figure out a way to still have
the human connection I can't just be
done by typing like this like it just
can't be done like that and I think we
really do need it and I think it also it
kind of kind of humanizes it and it kind
of you know people have different
concerns right my my grandmother in law
is 85 my mom my mom doesn't like when I
say her age but of my dad but you know
everyone's got different different
concerns right now and we need we really
need to be there for each other and I
and that's the other reason why I think
eliminating some of the really negative
voices with really partisan voices on
social media is really good right now
because it's an old game nobody wants to
play that game right now we have this
stuff out and that's why even right now
with this with this stimulus package
that's being held up by the Democrats
right now like regardless of what you
think about the package specifically and
and it seems like a pretty solid package
to me and we've got to make something
done but the idea that even right now
regardless if you're on the left of the
right you're Democrat Republican tatter
that Congress can't just put down the
[ __ ] for one second and make
something happen it's almost like it's
almost like they really are dinosaurs
and they're all in the Tar Pits right
now like they're slowly sinking and
their their ideas are old they're the
games that they play are old we all know
extinction is coming and what they're
doing instead of maybe you know trying
to get out of the Tar Pits right trying
to grab a branch and pull somebody out
with them it's like they're just like
come on guys let's just all sink
together and it's really really terrible
and and you know there's a couple
interesting things on on the political
side of this which is that as we watch
everybody fight about all what the
answers are for this and that and the
other thing it's like what might I
tweeted this yesterday but my personal
belief at the moment is well first off
we will get through this guys I know it
seems crazy and it's an
alone and you know I've really one of
the things I've really been thinking
about is for those of you that live
alone you know I've got David here we've
got Emma and we've had our employees
coming and going which obviously is
getting less and less now what what Oh
Clyde okay but you know so so we've had
you know I have people here and I've
been thinking a lot about just people
that that live alone you know if you if
you happen to be single maybe you just
broke up with somebody maybe you're not
with somebody maybe you're somebody
maybe you're your significant other was
across the country and now can't get
here or whatever it may be and I of
course I know there are many many people
that love being solo and there's really
nice things to it you know if you have a
nice weekend alone but anyway if there's
anything I can do to help the connection
with you guys I really want to do it I
tweeted out this morning this thing
about jobs if you've got a job or you
need a job and I really want to keep
fostering that and that's what we're
trying to build over at Rueben record to
help people connect with each other and
everything else so again you go to
Reuben record calm there's an iOS app
Google Play app all that other stuff so
what I want to do also is take some
questions from you guys
oh but sorry I didn't finish my thought
on the political part of this there's
some interesting things happening here
because on one hand you can see people
pushing for government should take over
everything take over all the
Corporations give everybody all the
money you bi for everybody you know all
of this stuff that's like one level of
what people are pushing and what I would
say is you know I saw somebody that I'm
not gonna throw under the bus at the
moment but I saw a former guest of this
show who is pretty much a libertarian
tweet out something to the effect uh
yeah I'm a libertarian but in times of
crisis you know if taking over
businesses and stimulus packages and Bob
a lot work then do it and it's like you
know you're on Brook has said this to me
many times if you don't have principles
when they matter you don't really have
principles so I'm not saying the
government shouldn't do anything right
now and I'm not gonna pretend I'm an
expert in this at all and I do think the
government has to do something I think
state governments have to do something
first and then federal government has to
do something as well
and we can talk about whether that has
to be helping businesses first because
then that allows people to have jobs or
just handing money to people so that
they
and spans which then helps business
right there's so many interesting ways
to look at this stuff and for the people
that just like you see this it's like a
Oh see all the solutions just so
happened to fit all her ideas perfectly
isn't that incredible even though she's
never run anything right all the ideas
just so happened to fit Bernie's
political ideology perfectly even though
he's never done anything like that stuff
is so boring to me when there's so many
interesting ways we can be thinking
about all this stuff and by the way
you're seeing right now all of these
companies come together and say you know
like there was this company that does
auto stuff and they're like we can use
our assembly line to build masks that's
private enterprise guys so we don't want
to lose all of our all of our ideals in
the midst of something crazy right and
you know also the more the more we give
away right we know this the more rights
we give away the more freedoms we give
away it's very rare that the government
will hand those types of things back and
we're in an uncharted space right now
and we have to be very careful about
that but at the political level it's
like alright there's some as long as the
economy doesn't completely crash and I
and I don't think I truly don't think it
will regardless of you know how bad this
gets our supply chain seems to basically
be working you know I went to the
supermarket two days ago I've been
trying to stay away from places
obviously but I was picking up some dog
food method alright let me just run two
super quick and the super was pretty
well stocked there weren't a ton of
people in there it was okay and I sense
from what I've seen like things are
being restocked and all that right
Amazon is really slow on on deliveries
but like things are happening right this
could be much much much much much worse
and that's why with the crew of people
that you know the burn it down crew Oh
America so horrible capitalism so
horrible and you know you see these
people that take pictures of an empty
aisle and they'll say oh I thought this
doesn't happen in capitalist countries
it only happens in socialist countries
and it's like yeah that that empty aisle
those shells they get restocked the next
day in capitalist America and in
capitalist countries so so but the
system is basically working but it is
being taxed right now in ways that it
probably has never been taxed before at
the same time that presents incredible
opportunity for direct consumer
businesses like Omaha Steaks and butcher
box and there's fish ones that all sort
things that get get immediate supplies
to people and Amazon and everything else
so there's opportunity but what I see
what I think I see on the horizon of
this politically is that let's say we
have a couple months of this which now
it sounds like we probably do have a
couple months of this in front of us at
some level maybe not all trapped in our
houses all time we're gonna I think
eventually like a phased you know if
you're under this age and healthy you
can go out and we'll have a phased
version of that but politically if the
economy doesn't crash which again I
don't think it will and we will get
through this I guarantee you of that we
will get through this
you know the borders issue is now a huge
win for conservatives right like borders
matter and it's obvious they matter and
if you want to just know some more my
thoughts on borders I think the guy
that's influenced me the most on this is
your Omkar zonie
who wrote the virtue of nationalism you
can find the interview that I did with
him that strong independent sovereign
nations and find a way to work together
with strong independent sovereign
nations everyone doing what's best for
their nation that's how you have a
global community not just some hegemonic
globalist thing that tells all the
nations what to do it's becoming very
obvious that borders do matter I saw
this ding-dong this Chris cilicia you
know this guy at CNN I mean this guy's a
real piece of work
Trump tweeted talking about strong
borders I think it was today or
yesterday and he tweets a viruses don't
know borders and it's like no that's not
true really I know it sort of sounds
glib and cute but you know a person
that's walking over a border that has a
virus might infect people on the other
side of that border you're allowed to
protect your border as you see fit every
country in the world by the way is
allowed to protect their border as they
see fit at least through by radical ends
so it's like these simplistic answers
and these people that you know this
whole nonsensical thing about is calling
it the Chinese virus or the Wuhan virus
racist I mean it's not racist China is
not a race China is a country Asian
people Asian is a race right so it's not
racist let's just put that aside but I
know people really struggle with that
thing but saying that a virus is from
somewhere right we know it's from Wu and
the city of Wu had in China say
that is not racist but but even putting
all of that aside the people bickering
over this are wasting such time you know
Peter Berg ozium brings up a good point
about this that any of these companies
that get infected by the social justice
thing the second they're infected by it
that means they're no longer doing their
core mission so whatever their mission
might be it could be a fire department
it could be a clothing cell you know a
closer department store whatever it
could be a book retailer it could
literally be anything whatever business
you're in imagine if the the job that
you're in the company has been infected
by social justice the second that
happens and they start worrying about oh
do we have this amount of X do we have X
amount of women and Z amount of black
people and there's all this nonsense
the core mission of whatever they're
supposed to be doing which is make
profit sell products you know produce
something maybe they're a non-profit
whatever it might be get their ideas out
there etc that is then skirted you're
missing something right you're you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're focusing on some sort of
imaginary thing so all of these people
that are that are screaming and fighting
about whether they're calling it the
China virus is racist it's just
silliness I saw a tweet from a extremely
well-known person who I met personally
maybe has even been on this show who I
won't throw under the bus but he tweeted
out this thing about how calling it the
the China virus is as racist as calling
it the Spanish flu and then of course
people find that between in last yearI
or two years ago that it was the Spanish
flu it's like what are we doing what are
we doing with ourselves guys it's it's
really it's really kind of nutty so
anyway all that being said the reason
I'm mentioning all that is don't get too
lost in that kind of stuff at the moment
and try to find a couple people that
sort of help you make get through this
and let's find other ways whether it's
having dinner together which which we're
gonna do this week with the Reuben
report community or watching movies
together or helping people find jobs or
helping your neighbor do something you
know you don't hug them and kiss them
and lick them but whatever it is or get
to your local whole animal shelter you
know they're all closing you know like
they're they're closing right now these
animal shelters they're gonna have to
put down dogs I mean Clyde was literally
he was an hour away they had that the
paint they showed me the paper was
signed like
he was going down and now he's hearing
alive and great so yeah I hope I know
you guys it's not like you need me to
tell you this stuff but I know we all
kind of get lost in the in just the
general lunacy of things all right so I
want to do a couple questions so you
guys can submit questions right now at
Rubin report.com or you can download the
iOS app just search Rubin Report or the
Google Play the Android app just search
Rubin Report I'll get to some questions
and thoughts and comments and things
okay between the wheel said how will
society be different after this what
changes can you foresee well I think
society is gonna be extremely dangerous
dangerous geez that was a strange
Freudian slip extremely different first
off we have to get through this right so
we have to get through this whatever
that means for just dealing with the
virus itself and then the economic
fallout and then let's not forget we
have an election which now seems almost
irrelevant and crazy right
by the way Biden did that little video
conference that it's like oh man they
really went with him they really did it
I'm still not convinced Biden's gonna be
the nominee by the way I honestly think
it's 50/50 it's you know four months ago
I was saying it was still 25% by him
then I moved it to 33% after Super
Tuesday when everyone said it's a
hundred percent him I still think the
DNC could do something and I don't know
that he can survive this thing and I
don't think he has the mental acumen and
it's just sad and depressing and
everything else but okay how is society
gonna be different well first off I hope
and I and I know many of you are I hope
you're taking this opportunity to really
think about your life seriously so this
would be like a Jordan Peterson element
of this thing like if you have that book
12 rules for life and you haven't read
it I've got it right here here here I'll
grab it if you've got 12 rules for life
and you haven't read it I would
recommend reading it and if you don't
have it and you can't get it delivered
you can download the e-book or the
digital version or whatever else but I
think so many of you when I'm when I'm
chatting with people all the time now
I'm hearing this so many of you guys
helped get your lives together not
you're not perfect right but like you
got you you sat up straight with your
shoulders back
right like you pet a cat when you see it
on the street although I'm highly
allergic to cats so I don't do that
but you get it I think I think perhaps
that at the moment there's a nice
opportunity for individual
responsibilities like right now wherever
wherever you're at you're most likely
you're in your room right now on a
laptop or you're at the at your desk or
something but you're most likely not at
work right now but even if you are at
work you're pretty solo right now we're
all kind of on our own right now we have
we have a small group of spouses and and
family and everything else but we're
scattered all over the place we're
trying to find those connections it's on
us like every every adult it's on you
right now to figure out how do you sort
of get through this so as I said like we
took care of getting supplies early we
started planting some stuff you know
like we started trying to do some things
in the last two weeks like David's a
really really great chef but I've been
cooking a lot I've been trying and I
like you know to learn those skills
which I've really enjoyed I also have we
you all have like a little more time
right a lot of you had to commute to
work now you're home like use this time
wisely like I've been trying to eat
right I've been conserving you know one
thing we're doing really well and I
would recommend you guys to do is try to
conserve some food when you can so
normally in the morning like simple
simple stuff
so normally in the morning I make a
French press so I do like basically
three tablespoons of coffee I grind it
up and I do it in a French press and
then usually I drink maybe maybe half of
that French press throughout the day
sometimes more depending on if I have
three shows and whatever else is going
on but I rarely drink a full French
press in today but I normally just pour
out that extra coffee well what I've
been doing now is that pour it into a
big jug and I put that in the freezer
and then that's been sorry in the fridge
and then that's next day's coffee so I'm
trying to conserve that we got red
onions at the store and you know you can
actually make red onions from red onions
so we started growing out the roots I
posted a picture on how to do it and
David gave some some tips on how to do
it at the Reuben report community and we
just planted some in a little little pot
in the back so we're gonna start growing
onions
there's things I think that we can all
do so when you say how it was society
going to be different I hope that people
are going to start thinking I can't
be so reliant all the time on all of the
things you know you mean I can't be so
reliant that always Amazon is gonna show
up an hour later when I need a freaking
you know I needed a new mouse or
something that people have Mouse Mouse's
the people have mice anymore
whatever you're ordering on Amazon you
got my point
I think realizing that you have to be a
little more reliant on yourself that you
should have some supplies and then this
actually sort of brings back to what I
was saying before about about borders so
like the Conservatives and the right are
gonna have a big win on borders I think
they're gonna have a big win on guns in
the next election because people want to
be able to defend themselves you know
even in the midst of this without
getting too dark I mean part of my
thinking with getting Clyde was like you
know it's it's nice having a dog in the
house they've done studies in crazy
well not in crazy times they've done
general studies where if you have a dog
in the house it's something like ninety
percent less chance for your house to be
robbed because if a robber is casing a
house and he's like oh I got a deal with
a freaking dog of that house or that
house doesn't have a dog and they look
pretty much the same I'm gonna go to
that house so I think just thinking
about your life in like a full holistic
way of how do you want to live how do
you not want to be so reliant on
anything I actually think and I really
do hope that a lot of the ideas that
I've talked about on the show about
about individualism and limited
government and and personal
responsibility of those things I
actually think they are gonna be
strengthened through this I think the
the place where the conversation will be
is right now how much power do we give
to the government to try to fix this and
can the government fix this and as I
said earlier should the government be
helping corporations because
corporations can then employ people and
then it's sort of goes that way or
should the government be giving direct
money to the people and then the people
can figure out what to do with their
money or you know and then the more
libertarian arguments the government
shouldn't do anything I do think the
government should do something so
there's there's all sorts of things but
you know the bigger problem with the
just general political the political
nonsense we're dealing with all the time
is you know they're putting in all their
pet projects and it makes try to hide
all of this stuff and then suddenly a
bill that's supposed to be
about fixing the economy as something
about abortion in it it's just the same
old political stuff and that's why I say
these guys are dinosaurs in the Tar Pits
and they're drowning themselves there
you're doing it to yourself if you guys
are watching this if you're a
congressman or congresswoman right now
and you're not just getting it done
you're doing itself so as as far as how
society change I think it will start
with us I think we will change I think
we are all realizing you know if you
were born in America after the baby
boomer generation you've really had no
struggles in America not to say there
haven't there have been struggles for
civil rights and and marriage equality
and all sorts of things so I'm not
diminishing those things but the real
stuff what it's been like to put food on
it take those things like were
confronted with that now we do have to
think about that now you know one of the
things that's been really disturbing I
think is you see all these people that
are like oh you know it's it's not so
bad the virus because it mostly affects
people that are 80 or older or 70 or
older or the mortality rate really jumps
at 80 baba it's like um do you people
have grandparents maybe have you ever
had grandparents I had I had my my
father's sorry my mother's father died
right before I was born his name was
David I was named after him by my
father's father died when I was in
second grade but I had two grandma
there's into my 30s and I had a great
grandmother into my 20s and I had a
great grandfather into my late teens I
liked all these people I was really glad
they were around and generally speaking
I really like older people my grandmas
first cousin Barbara just passed away
she was like 93 and she was amazing she
was a piano teacher teaching to her last
days in New York City incredible woman
so this idea of oh it's just killing old
people it's like you know we should
Revere old people I like learning from
old people they often have perspective
right they're better than the Twitter
BOTS so we've I think we have to just
start thinking about life a little bit
differently and I think this sowed what
I think is it'll strengthen local
communities I think it'll strengthen
families you know I'm feeling personally
as I said I've been calling my family
all the time
to face time in the rest of it I hope
you're doing that too it's like you
start you start realizing what's
important when we're all kind of trapped
in our families I think another thing we
should all be thinking about that's sort
of fallen off the map lately is is the
big tech question right you know we were
all like Oh big tech censoring us we
don't really talk about that anymore but
now big tech has has more of a
stranglehold than ever on us right
YouTube is letting me put this dream up
now but you know if some if they decided
not to or Twitter decided to do this or
the rest of it it's like we've now
because of how we're all communicating
with each other the big tech problem
just went exponentially bigger and we're
not really discussing that so we have to
think about that again that's why I
started locals and that's why I'm trying
to get as many of you guys over to the
Rubin report community as possible
because I think direct communication for
people is the future without big tech in
the way which is why we built the app
and you can get push notifications and
there's no algorithm messing with
anything or the rest of it so I hope you
guys will join us over there if you're
if you're interested in what I'm doing
at MIT we have ad free video and ad free
podcast and we'll build announced really
cool stuff and all that so I think
there's going to be major societal
changes but they're gonna be kind of
hard to see and I think it's gonna be on
all of us to figure out who are the
people that understand it and get it I
found one of the voices that I found
consistently consistently thoughtful and
interesting during this time is Scott
Adams who I've had on the show a couple
times the creator of Dilbert I think
he's been really good about enough being
totally alarmist but not booing it I
think he's actually a true original
thinker we were thinking maybe we'd do a
Skype later in the week so I may get him
on for that I'd love to hear some more
of the people that you guys think are
particularly interesting or thoughtful
or insightful in the midst of all this -
let's see there's a popular this is from
English politics there's a popular meme
going around that everyone loves
socialism in a crisis to me this is
silly because there's a difference
between a one-off stimulus package
during a crisis and a continuous payment
via government both are redistributed
but as long as the stimulus package is a
one-time thing or a short-term sunset it
shouldn't be considered socialism what
are your thoughts yeah I do agree with
that which is why I'm a little concerned
you know like a week ago there was this
really big push
for you bi universal basic income which
is you know the sort of Andrew yang idea
that you know I met you know will give
everybody checks each month and and you
know they can do what they want with the
money I get why people sort of like the
idea but I would rather just let people
keep their money I would rather scale
back government you want it you tell me
you're gonna chop the freaking federal
budget by a quarter and I guarantee you
none of us will know because the
government is giant and bloated so
instead of the government giving people
money I'd rather people just keep their
money in the first place so I'm not a
proponent of a view bi although I happen
to like Andrew Yang and I think he's a
decent guy but there was a big push for
it last week and it seems to have been
scale back but your general point and
actually I do think it very much fits
within what I would say is a classical
liberal approach to this is that you
don't want the government now taking
over everything forever in in the
socialist manner right and government's
gonna give money to everybody the
government's gonna take over factories
and all of these things you do not want
that but the idea that right now we are
an unprecedented crisis this is a case
where the government in my view the
government has to do something so this
is where I would say maybe there's a
little bit of a difference between which
people constantly ask me what is the
difference between libertarianism and
classical liberalism classical
liberalism
I think leaves room for enough sensible
government when it's needed but also
puts the parameters around it so that
this doesn't become something that the
government does forever that that's the
idea and I actually think in many ways
from what I've understood so far what
Trump has been presenting he's trying to
give companies as much leeway as
possible and he's you know he's getting
rid of some of the red tape around
experimental drugs and a whole bunch of
other things what you wanted to do is
you want to unleash the power of human
potential you want to unleash the power
of competition in capitalism so if
someone's got a good idea and it's an
antidote someone's got a good idea on
how to produce masks faster a gajillion
other things 3d printers that can help
doctors do this after that we want it we
want to unleash as much of that as
possible so maybe get rid of some
regulation that you that you might want
in some some more normal times and
things like that so I would say that a
one-time stimulus package or something
the sons debt to get us through the
economic hit that we're going through
right now so that the market doesn't
crash so that house values don't plummet
to make sure that you know the people
you know the unemployment rates are
spiking right now obviously we want to
do some things to help all of this but
what I would also say is you want as
much of this to be done by local
governments by state governments as
possible because not not everything is a
is a fit all thing so when you do a
stimulus package and it's like the
people of New York City don't
necessarily need the exact same thing as
the people of you know a rural town in
Montana and the and you know it costs
much more to live in New York City and
blah blah blah the the spatial
relationship between you and your
neighbor is different so that might mean
you need different financial things or
different different laws than all that
kind of stuff
gun laws and everything else so we have
to really think about these things so I
would give as much power to the states
as possible in this regard it sounds
like andrew Cuomo is doing a pretty good
job in New York from everything I
understand and he seems to be a pretty
calming voice in all of this which is
completely the reverse of his brother
Chris Cuomo on CNN who is just complete
complete buffoon okay let's see which of
Jordans rules this from Nick Kaufman
which of Jordans rules do you think are
the most important and pertinent during
this time I mean look the the simple one
of stand up straight with your shoulders
back the point of it is the essence of
it is is kind of get your [ __ ] together
so that you can be a voice of reason
like you have to be a voice of reason
with yourself first and then you can for
the world this I think is the biggest
challenge all of us have it's like to
look at your life seriously and then
figure out how to how to live it the
best way right we all struggle with this
all the time I think it's like the
question in life but you know especially
right now I think we need people that we
can look to that you're like oh that
that is a person who is modeling some
sort of behavior that is is good in a
time of crisis is is not is not losing
it in the midst of all of this is living
in a way
that is not crazy and that's why you
know what I've really again I've been
really trying on social media and even
what I did with the shows last week
right we did two shows on coronavirus
with experts this week we're putting up
a show with Dennis Miller that we have
actually taped right before this all
broke but I thought you know what can I
could do another show this week with we
could Skype in you know another expert
on corona but I don't want you guys to
be slammed with just that like I'll
share information as I see it fit as it
seems pertinent but I also want life to
go on and actually Dennis Miller duei
I'd never met before he was really
really funny and a totally nice guy like
we really really hit it off and I
thought like let's let's get a little
escapism which by the way is why we're
doing the movie thing why we did it iakh
recei yesterday why we'll do the dinner
thing so I think I think standing up
straight with your shoulders back I mean
saying to the world I'm here I'm not
losing my [ __ ] I'm trying to deal with
it and and move forward through that I
think it's I just you know it's the one
that I quote all the time it's probably
the the most quoted one but I think
there's probably a reason for that you
know the the pet a cat on a street if
you see one you know the idea really is
is you know enjoy life you know don't
forget the small things so it's not
about a cat specifically but I think in
a time like this too that is important
don't it's why I've been trying to still
be silly on Twitter too and and the rest
of it because we can't we need humor in
the midst of all this we need an ability
to appreciate what's happening in life
and everything else ok let's see where
do you think Bernie Sanders crowd goes
from here they tied all their hopes to
Bernie and then the DNC basically
destroyed him he's old this has got to
be his last hurrah yeah real quick
because I just don't want to do too much
on like the the pure political stuff at
the moment
Bernie's done Bernie's done you know his
best bet right now is to try to extract
some concessions out of Biden but the
DNC has had it with him the party hates
him he's led the progressives to ruin
several times over and by the lights can
get much worse for progressives for the
reasons that I just said because his
intersectionality and social justice and
all of that stuff and Pro gender
pronouns could that possibly be more
relevant than it is right now because
now reality is more relevant reality is
more hitting us all in the face right
now
so as I said conservatives now win on
borders and on guns and on China and a
bunch of things where all of the
nonsense that he's been screaming about
all seems irrelevant so an Elizabeth
Warren is like being gone done you know
she was gonna hire a trans person to be
the trans guardian of trans issues in
trans town it's like nobody's against
trans people Elizabeth but your silly
identity politics games they seem
completely irrelevant so the sad part
for Bernie is they have to destroy him
now and you can already see I think AOC
is hinting it a little bit they have to
destroy him now because that's what this
movement is it's it's a snake that eats
its own tail and Bernie didn't win and
he didn't take out Hillary last time
which a lot of them wanted to he's gonna
go quietly into the night here and
eventually back Biden and the real
radicals of party which is what the
energy of the left is right now have to
destroy they have to turn on him now and
say see he wasn't true he wasn't a true
believer he wasn't a true Marxist
communist Stalinist like we are and they
have to take him out and it was
obviously time and they'll be the ones
that destroy his legacy the
Conservatives and the people on the
right or whatever they're gonna be like
Oh remember that Bernie Sanders you know
he made some noise but he was just an
old annoying socialist but the ones that
are gonna truly burn the legacy of
Bernie Sanders and say he was a sellout
and he worked with evil Joe Biden who
voted for the Iraq war and blah blah
blah blah blah it's gonna be his own
people so Bernie is done let's see the
see this is sports fan
the CDC dictates that people should be
no closer than six feet I have seen that
thus all sports leaks have been shut
down for the next several weeks why
can't two PGA golfers play a
pay-per-view match with no caddies walk
their own bags with cameramen hundreds
of feet apart with cameraman over camera
man hundreds of feet apart on the course
would this not be the highest-grossing
pay-per-view of all time it would also
not give people jonesing for something
together on a big event yeah it's a good
idea like actually right now but but
again this is why I'm hopeful right now
I think there are so many interesting
opportunities right now if you're a
golfer get out there in golf and have
your brother or somebody your wife
while your if it's your wife you can
hopefully be next to them or you know
some trusted person can just be on an
iPhone live streaming on YouTube and
then you know when you have to and then
you jump in the cart after each stroke
and then you talk about golf or talk
about life like there's that it's
exactly what I'm trying to do here I
think there's so many interesting
opportunities if you're a basketball
player and you're stuck at home right
now you know instead of playing video
games and I have nothing against video
games I actually just me and being my
buddy one of my other childhood buddies
my buddy Ari
we just bought John who I mentioned to
you earlier we just sent him a
PlayStation at his house so we can all
hook up headphones and play we haven't
had a freaking moment to do it
but we thought that would be fun it
would be like we're in seventh grade
again so we're gonna try to do it
tonight for a couple minutes but if
you're a basketball player or you're a
baseball player or something like you're
a baseball player what an easy when
you're a pitcher you're a baseball
pitcher and you love baseball and you
can't play right now and you're supposed
to be in spring training it's like man
set up a camera have your son catch and
show people how to throw a great
curveball you know like all of that
stuff you're an infielder show people
how to field show people how to swing I
mean and forget your sports I mean
there's a million things that we can do
here my mom is a is a retired nursery
school teacher she's now got my
five-year-old niece and two year old
nephew she's doing some teaching at home
again you know there's so many things
that people can do I think the ability
to telecommuting work from home there's
there's ways we can all do things better
and learn some new skills and I saw you
know one of the people in the Reuben
rapport community is teaching online
yoga now let's share music with each
other I've been posting just different
different playlists on Spotify that I
like you know like let's let's we can
there we can share our lives in a new
way I think because of all this let's
see em tickle says hey Dave I can't be
the only one who's watching the
hyperbole and in some cases lies
visualizing this as a means to
transition towards central planning
thoughts yeah I mean I'm definitely
concerned about that right like I don't
and that's why I'm saying as per the
earlier question that you don't want
long-term takeovers of industry what you
want are short-term stimulus is to get
us through the hump right that is the
duty of government is to keep the wheels
on the thing if nothing else right and
then with some sort of sunset clause so
like it doesn't
forever nothing will last forever you
know what we don't want at the end of
this is we don't want to get through
this
whatever that means X amount of people
die but we get through this the economy
takes a hit but then suddenly we realize
holy cow we now have an extra five
million people on the government dole
because the problem is and this is just
human nature when people get on the
government or they don't get off the
government dollar and then the
government always increases its budgets
because government offices work
basically the way a government the way a
governmental office works is you got to
spend the budget you get you get a
budget doesn't matter what office here
and you get a budget if you don't spend
that budget they cut your budget the
next year so you always spend it or over
so that they give you more no business
could ever operate like this and that
shows why the government of of it every
country but the United States you know
where trillions in debt why are we in
debt because we always spend more so yes
I am worried that whatever we do here
has more long-term effects that will
hamper freedom that will hamper Liberty
if we just have the government take over
everything so we do have to be very
worried about that
let's see um whatever happened to that
thing that was all over the news before
coronavirus you know the thing with the
old guys the Democratic primaries that's
it I mean yeah it just seems so
irrelevant right now it just seems so it
seems so crazy you know another thing
related to Trump is that you know like
Trump hate Trump whatever if you're not
just like a crazed you know he's Hitler
person you know Trump for better or
worse is an executive right like it's
very obvious he hires people he fires
people he makes decisions he hands off
things to other people he delegates all
of that that as a general set of skills
he's a good thing to have I'm not saying
he's perfect that if by any stretch but
like has a general set of skills it's
good thing that right now if you imagine
if Bernie was in charge right now
Bernie's never run anything alright he's
run he's run for office I don't really
consider that accomplishing anything
building anything like there's no reason
to think that as a decision maker he is
the final decision-maker that can
actually figure out how to make things
happen properly that he could hire the
right people to make things happen
probably I'm not saying Trump is hired
all the right people
but you want people that make decisions
and then you have to live with those
decisions so you hope that those
decisions are good ones but yes even
thinking about the election right now is
kind of crazy and again I just have a
feeling it's not gonna be Biden I do
let's see mmm calling for a three-month
time out on all rent mortgage loan
payments would help us through this I
saw Larry Sharpe suggest this ever
consider getting him on the show well
I've had Larry sharp on Larry Sharpe was
libertarian running for governor of New
York didn't do particularly well but I
think but you know New Yorkers are not
as a general rule a very libertarian
minded I think they I think they are in
their hearts like a New Yorker I'm a New
Yorker like it's the most like
individualistic thing there is but then
you get live in a big city and suddenly
you want the government kind of doing
everything not the New York City is all
of New York obviously and there's a lot
of tension actually between New York
City and Albany which is the state
capital because there's tension between
the amount of funds that the city gets
versus what the rest of the state gets
Larry sharks a really good guy and he's
a really good thinker and I'm happy to
have him on again the idea of suspending
rent payments mortgages and that sort of
thing
look it's one of those things that you
really have to think it through so let's
say let's say you do that now you're
helping the immediate people right now
first off not everyone needs help right
now so I think you do have to figure out
ways that it's not fair like like my
business for example in the midst of
this you know we're doing pretty good
right I can do this I'm doing this for
my from my computer today but I do have
a home studio and as long as my people
can get here which is tenuous actually
at the moment but we can basically
function I'm gonna be on Tucker Carlson
this week from my house and Dana Perino
and a couple other things I don't get
invited to do people always over CNN and
their MSNBC they don't they don't ask I
can't just show up but I you know I can
pretty much function as a business here
we've made sure that our employees are
gonna be paid and all that kind of stuff
so if you were gonna have like a
mortgage break at the moment you know
you have to make sure it doesn't go to
everybody I can afford my mortgage
thankfully at the moment you guys that
support us allow us to do that because
by the way our videos last week on
coronavirus were demonetized so when I
do valuable things there do one of them
got monetized a few hours later one of
them I think
like to monetize but you get all of
those views at the beginning so I can't
trust YouTube as a as a business model
which again is why we started ripping
apart common people throw in a couple
bucks it it gets us there so we're good
but you would want to make sure that tom
hanks who maybe has crota virus but he
doesn't need his mortgage not to be paid
so you have to figure out ways that
you're helping the people who actually
need it not just throwing money you know
the simple answer is to just throw money
at everything but the idea of saying
that that loan payments may be for
certain things you know school payments
let's say school loan payments are for
six months while we figure this out and
that that rent and mortgage you know for
people of X income or if you've lost
your job you know something like that
I would want as much of that to be done
by the states as possible but I but
something like that actually makes
complete sense to me that's a way you
can help people now what you want to
make sure you're doing also is you want
to make sure then you're not completely
screwing the the people that own the
property so an example would be let's
say you've got a guy who's doing okay
right he's doing pretty good he makes
150 grand a year because he owns a
couple properties and rents out a lot of
things and he's doing pretty good and he
doesn't need a break himself but now if
you say to that guy all right well you
can't charge rent to all of your people
well now suddenly he has no income and
now this $150,000 guy is hurt too so you
really have to think of all of the
cascading things that happen with all of
this stuff and that's why that's why
politics is so crazy because you get
these people in here that just oh we
know exactly how to do it we've never
done it before we've never actually
accomplished anything but we know how to
do it and by the way it so happens to
fit every single thing that I've been
screaming about for two years that's
really just not reality we have to
figure out how to have some mature ways
to discuss this actually one of the
things that I want to do I think we're
trying to set it up right now actually
is I want to do a show on the economic
fallout of this through the principles
that I always talk about here right
through classical liberal and
libertarian principles how could you do
a short-term stimulus package that would
make sense through that so we're going
to do that with an expert probably
within the next week or so
let's see so a lot of you are asking a
lot about that what are your thoughts on
the education system and how they're
handling the situation so I really like
the idea that as many schools from what
I can tell at least and from listening
to my brother and sister who have kids
in the school system you know as many
schools that can go online as possible I
think it's it's obviously great you know
zoom I'm doing zoom to do these movie
nights with people and you can get in
zoom I can be getting a hundred people
all at once in a thing so little classes
you can still teach it's a little it's a
little different I would want to empower
teachers to be able to do as much of
that as possible you know the real issue
here is right now it seems to me I don't
see how schools come back this year
you know this calendar well no I think
it come back this calendar year but this
semester I think probably schools don't
won't come back till September because
let's say right now we have let's say we
have just have a month of this right now
which some people are predicting far
more but if we have a month of this
right now now we're in the middle of
middle to end of April now the school
year usually ends some schools and late
May most most are ending by mid-june
well how do you pack all that in and if
you say all right well we're gonna
extend it through the summer like you
start the amount of you know parents
that have other obligation like there's
a million things again the cascading
effects of all of these things so I
think we have to do as much as we can
I mean think how actually guys think how
truly blessed we are that we are going
through this in 2020 and not 1920 right
we are able to communicate right now
imagine imagine what it was like in
times past when pandemics and epidemics
and flus and plagues and all of these
things happen where you didn't know what
would happen if you walked outside you
didn't know what was happening three
houses over much less across the across
the country much less across the world
so excuse me I'm just caught don't worry
I'm gonna watch this hand I know where
this hands been just thank you
so we're living in this like tech
technological adolescence in the midst
of all this - and we have to think about
that but there's a beauty in it right
like there is a bee
we can most of us the people that are
telecommuting right now oh this is one
of the things when you asked about how
society is gonna change I think it's
becoming increasingly obvious that most
people can telecommute don't need to be
in traditional offices anymore and I
think what that will do is when people
realize that I think a lot of people
that right now that let's say work in
New York City that are paying crazy
crazy high rents I live there most in my
life
to be to work at an office and then you
get all sorts of ancillary benefits by
living in New York City there's a
gajillion great restaurants you've got
Lincoln Center you've got Central Park
all those things but you're living in a
really expensive thing too often as my
as my sister describes it to live in her
little box you know I think people are
gonna realize wait a minute wait a
minute I don't need to be going to that
office I could be I could telecommute do
most of my work remotely and I could
live somewhere else somewhere more rural
more suburban feel safer not be around
as many people I so I think actually
there's gonna be some interesting
migration patterns that happened after
this and I think by the way that some
people have been well ahead on this I'll
give a [ __ ] out out to my man Chris who
who works with us who does all our
YouTube back-end stuff who's done an
absolutely great job who we worked with
for about two years now I never even met
him in person until about three weeks
ago he came out with his wife and
daughter and we met for the first time
in person but we've been telecommuting
and video chatting and phone calling and
I think there's all sorts of ways that
people can do and he lives he lives in
New York right now I'm in California we
lived 3,000 miles apart we've worked
together for two years never even met
until three weeks ago I mean there's
really cool things that I think
technology can now aid us in as we go
through this so I think the way where
people live is gonna change I mean
there's so many things the way
industries are gonna change I mean movie
theaters right now I said to David last
night I haven't read anything about this
but what movies were supposed to be out
in the last two weeks I mean if you had
a big-budget movie studios are losing a
ton of money right now are they
immediately sending them to Apple movies
are they trying to push them all onto
Netflix right now and if they do and the
more all of us are online do we have to
figure out new ways to do broadband and
how does that affect you know if we're
gonna go with five G and the a million
issues around that
and are we gonna have lag times on on
the internet I mean there's a million
things to think about right now but you
know I I really think and this is why I
say the most important rule is to sit up
straight with your shoulders back if we
can just remain calm and to think about
those options I think we're gonna be in
good shape you know one of the examples
that I would hear Jordan talk about on
the tour about this was you know a lot
of times people come to him and they'll
say well they hate their job and it's
like aren't you hate your job I'm
quitting my job well alright you but you
can't just quit tomorrow most likely
right let's just say you don't have a
trust fund you can't just quit tomorrow
you know I hate my job but what I have
to do is I got to get my resume together
I got to look at my budget I got to
think do I family to support
do I have mortgage to pay blah blah blah
car payments everything else and look at
it maturely look at your life maturely
and we all kind of struggle with this at
times right like I struggled with all of
those things budgeting and and you know
all all of those personal stuff that we
all struggle with I think I'm getting
pretty good at it now and I think what
this will force people to do is look at
their lives more seriously and say what
do I really want do I just want to go
along with the system that in many ways
doesn't seem to really care about me or
function that well while at the same
time again our system here is still I
would still rather be in America right
now than anywhere else right it's a it's
a little whacked out right now but all
countries are having problems and again
like the Border's thing it's like these
people that were screaming about open
borders well now Canada shut their
border to America America shut their
border to Canada even even the brexit
situation you know I think the UK is
probably pretty happy that they're out
of regs it and can have better control
over their borders and and you know you
can see what's happening in Italy which
hasn't extremely I think I think the
oldest population in the world and that
which is one of the reasons they're
struggling so much but then you see
these incredible videos of people in
apartment buildings in Italy singing out
of their windows because because humans
have a desire to be free to be happy to
find connection and I think we send
something really good about that that
will happen after all this okay let's
see
what games are you playing on
playstation so as I said I so he got my
buddy John a PlayStation and I just
haven't had a moment yet because you
know we ended up getting the dog and
like we're doing some other stuff around
here and I've been dealing you know I've
been trying to garden and just like do
things that are a little more
particularly important at the moment but
I did finally turn the PlayStation on
yesterday I had to do like a gajillion
updates because it hadn't been on in so
long but I you know if you have some
recommendations please let me know
because so you know I I like generally
playing the sports games like with my
nephew we play online when we can but I
don't like you like I don't have like
major first time I don't have a lot of
time and I can't like devote my life to
it right so like I like sort of games
that are somewhat mindless so I think
the game that I'm gonna play with with
my buddies I told them to download is
just Marvel Ultimate Alliance you know
you all pick a superhero you're just
punching through a lot of stuff and
shooting things and blowing things up
but it's you know the screen you're kind
of looking down sort of like an
old-school gauntlet way so it's not that
you know I don't really like running
into the screen that way I just get lost
I'm more of a Mario Brothers guy I got
to go that way I don't even like going
that way I'd prefer to go this way
but I could do it this way so uh so that
but I also have old-school Nintendo here
and playing contra up up down down left
right left right B a select start I'm
totally good to go on that front but if
you've got some recommendations let me
know are you gonna do pay-per-view for
the event in Anaheim so the book tour so
I have not heard yet that the book tour
is officially postponed a few people
started sending me screenshots that
they're getting messages from Live
Nation that the tour is post one I'm
assuming at this point the tour was
supposed to start on April 28th in New
York like probably not happening then so
obviously we're gonna move all the dates
we just started a big email chain about
how we could do some pay-per-view events
or you know livestream kind of things so
stay tuned down all that don't worry if
you bought a ticket by the way and
thousands of you guys bought tickets
already which you know it's awesome and
also like but yes we will figure that
out door you're not gonna lose your
money on the ticket we're gonna figure
out all that stuff there's a you know
try to imagine the amount of events that
have to be rescheduled and booked things
that have to be I mean all of that stuff
to be has to be dealt with but don't
worry you're not gonna lose your money
and we you know look I told the
publishers when I had the the big call
with penguin the other day you know they
and they were talking about Dave do you
want to delay the book launch and we're
delaying a lot of other stuff and I was
like no we go ahead and do it we will do
the best we can I don't I said they're
released they told me how many how many
books they're releasing the first week
and we know we've sold a ton already and
there really seemed like a really crazy
amount despite all this and I said to
the guy I will if I have to sign book
legs for every single person because I
know it's a pain to have a book deliver
or what I thought pains that book
deliver like everything's just up in the
air if I have to if I have to literally
sit in this room and sign book plates
for three straight days so my hand falls
off I'll do it I wanted I believed in
this book I think it's it's probably the
best work I've ever done I think the
idea is that you know that we're
presenting in this book I think they're
the right ideas for right now that
Jordan Peterson guy by the way who who
we mentioned a couple times topical
engaging personable and above all
reassuring here you know what I'll just
sit on the back of the book I'll just
read a couple of these Dave Reubens
genuine curiosity and willingness to
seriously consider options across the
political spectrum have rightly made the
Rubin Report and necessary corrective to
modern journalism
don't burn this book charts his personal
and political transformation from
predictable progressive to independent
and into sorry to independent an
informed thinker in a manner that his
readers should find topical engaging
personable and above all reassuring
that's that's from Jordan real quick
from Shapiro Dave Reubens willingness to
have tough conversations with those whom
he disagrees has made him a political
force and a target this book shows why
this one here's it here's one that you
may not have thought I got on this book
Dave Rubin is bridging America's divide
he Great Divide he reminds us that while
we may not always agree with the other
we need to listen to them Rubin has
mastered the vital skills of listening
and of asking questions that do not
serve an ideological agenda that's F
carte totally from the power of now
I don't know that Eckart totally ever
thought he'd be on the back of the book
with Jordan Peters and Ben Shapiro
Peter Thiel Dave Rubin has been years
ahead of the mainstream media for years
incredible that did that the theater did
that Dave Rubin is one of the bravest
smartest people I know as well as a
tremendous television presence that's
Tucker Carlson and then my man Dave
Rubin is one of them one of a kind a
truly great interviewer bright curious
and funny that's Larry King so anyway I
really wanted to get this thing out and
we are not going to delay it and I and I
just believe as a general rule in life
as I'm holding a big mouth I have the
other book here about rules in life you
just keep going you just keep going so I
was like no we're not gonna delay this
thing we will figure out a way to make
it happen so yes don't worry about the
tour
it will all be rescheduled and if in the
meantime I have I'll do free videos I
mean whatever I got to do I'll do I
promise you
let's see couple others here are you
planning on doing meetups after your
tour events yeah we would love all that
all the tour questions and I see a
couple others here we got to figure out
all of that stuff all of the events by
the way we were doing meet-and-greets
after where you know if you buy the VIP
ticket you get to meet me I can take
pictures sign the book a little private
talk you know now just everything's up
in the air just give us a chance to get
get that in order and we will get it
there
let's see Dave can you tell us a little
more about the process of recording the
audiobook version of don't burn this
book I'm glad yes so I did that last
week actually so for three days last
week in the midst of this corona lunacy
I went to a studio in West Hollywood and
first off driving through Hollywood was
weird because Hollywood is is sort of
becoming like a very San Francisco like
sort of just homeless dystopian
apocalyptic it's really really gross
West Hollywood's not not as bad on that
front but you have to drive through
Hollywood from where I am to get to to s
hi ode and there's really nobody else on
the street so it was like very weird
basically you go in there was one guy in
there they they you know normally it
have some more people there but they're
on a skeleton crew as well they made
sure to sanitize the whole thing you sit
in a tiny little audio booth so
technically I actually could have done
it from our studio here but you guys
know that during the show I usually wear
a lab which is just like you know the
mic that we tend to to the shirts those
are not the highest quality mics and
obviously although we've done
nice job soundproofing this place and I
I know some of you guys have seen it
before but you know we've got sound
panels that you can see everywhere and
we do a nice job of that and some
seriously expensive lights I'll tell you
that much
it's our our audio quality here I'm not
I mean a tiny soundproof booth that is
absolutely perfect so even though we
could have done it here obviously I
wanted to do the best possible quality
so you go in there you've got an iPad
the books right in front yeah and and
you read through and you have a director
I had a director who is actually in New
York and then I have the engineer in Los
Angeles and you read through and when
you're on a nice roll they don't say
anything and every now and again they
want you to repeat a line or they want
you to hit a particular word a little
differently or on a joke they want you
to pause a little bit more or there
might be something where you know I sort
of trampled over a word in like a very
passionate sentence or something
I thought really enjoyed it like I
actually really liked it was fun being
in the booth David's been saying to me
for a long time I should do voice-over
stuff and like he could see me doing
like cartoon voices and things and I
really liked being in the booth there's
there's something that I just I don't
know I felt very at home there so maybe
I'll do some more of that kind of stuff
in the future but basically it's funny
so get there and I did it in three days
the books about 220 pages or so 230
pages and it took me about three days to
do and the reason for that is you know
you could probably do it all in a day if
you could just literally talk from 8
a.m. to 8 p.m. non-stop and whatever you
want kill yourself again but really
after after five hours of talking and
you know because sometimes you have to
repeat yourself and everything else my
throat each day when I walked out it was
killing me and you know we're in the
middle of this Corona thing and it's
like man am I am I like ripping up my
throat which is gonna somehow make my
throat more susceptible to getting germs
in there and so I didn't want to kill
myself each time so it took it ended up
taking me about two and a half days I
went in for two full days at about a
half day on the third day and yeah I
enjoyed the process I really I'm really
proud of the book I think you guys are
really gonna like it you know in my one
thing is like I kind of wish that it had
come out before Corona because
we're also we're also up in this for all
the right reasons
but I think that the ideas that I lay
out in the book are not I think I know
that the idea is that I lay out in the
book are completely applicable to
everything that's happening right now so
so I'm super excited for the book to
come out actually I shot a new Prager u
video about the main idea of the book
which will come out on April 27th and
the book comes out on April 28th my tape
it's a interview with Candace Owens
which will come out right around then
hurt me on her show I went on Josh pecks
podcast I have a whole bunch of other
interviews being planned oh and I will
tell you one one other thing which I
haven't said publicly before but I got
finally after all of these years I got
booked on Real Time with Bill Maher for
May 29th but then like literally I kid
you not like two days later we found out
that they were suspending it for the
season so we don't know what's gonna
happen with that but they're so there's
a real bittersweet thing there right
like I mean I wanted to be on
politically incorrect which was Bill's
show before that was his show on ABC
before real time which ended right after
9/11 when he gotten he was one of the
first victims of canceled culture after
he said something about the hijackers I
don't want to get into all that right
now but I wanted to be on that show for
years right when I started stand-up I
started stand-up in 98 May of 98 so I
wanted to be on Bill's show for over 20
years literally over 20 years like that
was the gig that I wanted the one thing
that I probably want more than that is
Howard Stern but putting Stern aside for
a sec finally got the email from the
publicist that I'm booked on Bill Maher
then they get suspended for the season
so life works in weird ways you know the
funny thing is that in the last couple
months I had sort of gotten over it in a
way I was kind of like you know what I'm
just doing my thing and I just I don't
like wanting something like that anymore
you know like I spent a lot of time in
life we you know we all do this right he
spent a lot of time in life wanting
certain things for certain reasons and
like I'm good I'm good I'm very proud of
what we're doing
here I'm very happy with what we're
doing et cetera and I had sort of gotten
over it really and I had even jokingly
said
even a couple times in the last year I'm
like you know if I ever get the call to
be on real time it's gonna be kind of a
letdown if anything now of course if the
season gets picked back up or if they
end up going back to next season or
whatever I will be glad to do it
I think bill and I could have an
incredible discussion because we we are
both old school free speech liberals you
know he's got more of the Trump
derangement stuff he's gotten into
personal fights with Trump so I don't
even grudge him some of that stuff but I
think ultimately he's more of like just
like a pot-smoking libertarian that has
been sort of crossed up by a lot of the
progressive nonsense but then at the
same time it's like who hates Bill Maher
the most it's the progressives it's it's
the lefties the Conservatives always
like Oh Bill Maher is a good liberal I
just disagree with him on everything I
would love to have that conversation
like how cool would that be actually
right we're generationally different we
have a different perspective on these
things I think it would be an amazing
conversation so anyway I got booked then
the season got suspended so I don't know
what God's saying to me but yeah there
we are on that um okay let's see will
you have to Orton Peterson on anytime
soon so I I don't want to say anything
about Jordan that you know his team
hasn't released I can tell you he's
getting better I can tell you he'll be
back I know he's gonna be back and he's
gonna be great just give him a little
bit of time and of course we'll get in
here I know and I know he's working on
another book um a lot of questions are
about the stimulus packages and making
sure that they don't stick around for
too long so I think we've already hit
that this is a good one our reasoning
says does this emphatically and
unexpectedly put an end to the whole
open borders thing specifically in
Europe or will they keep going the same
way as before you know one of the
interesting things about this so is that
you know one of the way the left has
operated over the last couple years and
and I think why many of you guys came to
this show was that I just started saying
well the left doesn't seem to ever stop
it doesn't seem to ever look in the
mirror it doesn't never take any
self-reflection Donald Trump is
president you might go oh maybe we did
something wrong here and they never do
that and so this is an interesting
question because it's like now
as there is a massive pandemic
throughout the world as people in the
United States of America in the freest
country the world our quarantine and our
homes might the left go oh we should
think a little bit differently about
borders you know that you can't just let
people wander through into different
countries that if you come across
illegally you got to go back I mean a
million a million things because the
funny thing is when when the rubber hits
the road which is hitting right now what
are countries doing they're closing
their borders and that's the thing if
you have ideas that that you think work
but then suddenly something happens so
now you have to go oh do my ideas work
and you just plow through them anyway
well then your ideas are not good so it
is very obvious to even someone like
Justin Trudeau who brings back Isis
fighters hang out in Canada lovely fella
so welcoming um he's even realizing that
borders matter so I think the borders
thing ultimately is a major win for
Trump here as I said China is guns are I
think the state's right stuff I mean I
think there's a lot of wins in it for
him
I think cutting regulation is also a win
you know they're getting rid of the red
tape so that we can test out some of
these medications and things and by the
way Trump's been fighting for that
forever right to try laws and things
like that so we'll the question really
though is will they backtrack on some of
their open borders stuff I think the
Train the way these people operate I
know it seems crazy but the way these
people operate is they believe in their
ideas at a legislature not a rational
nature and that's why they're more upset
with whether you call this the Chinese
virus or the Wuhan virus rather than
what the mortality rates are like they
really are seemingly more upset by that
because it's this is religious in nature
and what I'm more concerned about is
this guy look at him let's go we'll do a
little pause there man when he fell
asleep not last night the night before
no that was a good you're on
you know after after probably a couple
weeks just totally stray and then being
in the shelter amongst all the other
dogs when we went to the shelter and got
him you know he's in this room they do
the best
they camera but they're overloaded in
all sorts and stuff and there were all
these yipping dogs and he was actually
the biggest dog in in the room that he
was in probably about 15 dogs in there
and they're yipping and barking whatever
and he was just freaked out like you can
see you know some dogs you sees people
that don't like being around people he
was freaked and it's like the second he
got into this house we took him off the
collar he bolted around like you know
dog young dogs they get bazooms I think
that's what they call him
he bolted around like holy cow I am home
I'm good and now he's happy and good and
what are you doing what are you doing
heating my hand
anyway the Border's thing I think I
think you get my point I don't know that
they'll turn back because you know the
globalists portion of this especially in
Europe like they just believe that these
boarders shouldn't exist just because
they shouldn't and that bankers in
brussels should have much as much to do
in your life in Italy and in Germany as
your local government that's just crazy
to me but it'll it will be interested
what will be interesting to see is what
happens to the Democratic Party here
right because the Democratic Party
whether you like their ideas or not they
they are a machine that wants to win so
when they took out Bernie and by the way
again nobody stole the election from
Bernie right like the fact that Budaj
edge and Klobuchar and Warren that the
fact that they all dumped out is not and
then and then I don't do more never
support Biden do we know about that I
kind of missed it if that happened but
the rest of them the fact that they all
dumped out and even yang and and Tulsi
and all supported by me is not stealing
it from Bernie right everyone got to
vote it's it's that they or everyone's
playing politics that's what politics is
it's it's a dirty game right you may not
like the game but don't you know hate
the player hate the game don't hate the
game hate the player which one is it
wait don't hate the player hate the game
or don't hate the game hate the player
don't write don't hate the player hate
the game right like the game is messy
Jesus um it's it's a messy game so the
point is that nobody was cheated Bernie
was not cheated but the Democratic
machine said but Biden they decided
Biden gives us better chance and when I
say they I mean the party leaders those
candidates everybody that's what they
decide it right and
for Biden right now and the DNC it's
like well what do we do we've been
screaming about illegal immigrants don't
call them illegal and we've been
screaming about of war open borders and
we should give health care to all of
these people who aren't even citizens
and we should you know Biden said the
thing he said the thing to Beto about
you're gonna handle the gun thing for me
well these are losing issues for you
guys so does the DNC now start moving
back to the center does Biden move back
to the center Biden who I do actually
think is more of a centrist and got
totally lost in the social justice
nonsense I don't know interesting but
would anyone trust him at that point
and yeah I just don't see that as a win
for them either then it's just like oh
you then the base really hates you even
more because the base is religious in
nature so it's an interesting question
we'll see let's see you know I'll do one
more question I see there's a ton here
I'll try to for those of you that I
didn't get to I'll try to respond to
some of them by text within the comment
section at Rubin report.com what's the
hardest part for you and David these
days from James regard that's it that's
a good one
David can I give a little personal
information here yeah all right well I
will tell you guys this I have not said
this publicly before but we are trying
to expand our family and not just in the
in the dog kind so in the midst of all
this craziness actually on Friday when
what we officially adopted Clyde earlier
in the day we were at the IVF clinic and
we were don't not donating our sperm we
were what were we doing what were we
doing with it
depositing I keep saying donating we
weren't giving our sperm Aleida regular
people we were depositing our own sperm
and we are trying to find an egg and
then ultimately a surrogate and we're
trying to we're probably gonna have to
two kids and we're doing and you know
everybody's canceling appointments and
they're delaying IVF and surrogacy
thinking they don't want to and there's
a million things the doctor was willing
to see us so we did deposit this firm
I'm not going to get into the specifics
of that but you know it was it was a sea
really crazy time to be doing it
actually I tweeted a picture I didn't
say where I was going but as we were
walking into the sperm clinic Dennis
Rodman rode by us on a skateboard this
is life is weird so anyway we're in the
midst of that and we've been planning it
for quite some time and having all sorts
of conversations about how we want to do
it why we want to do it and timing and
you know a million other things and
unfortunately right now they're delaying
a lot of the the implants and everything
else for a few months while while they
figure out what's going on with corona
but we wanted to make sure that at least
our sperm was taken care of there's a
sentence I've never said before so that
the second we find the Right donor we
can make sure that we can you know get
her you know get get the eggs and even
if they can't do the process just yet
and they still have to do extra
screening on us and on her and then
ultimately on the surrogate because
basically what we're doing is we're
taking our sperm I think we're gonna try
to have two kids one but from the same
egg right so the donor will have couple
eggs my sperm will go to one David's
will go to another and then we'll
hopefully up to children which maybe
will be done as twins and maybe we'll be
done separately which is then two
surrogates in whole it's a whole bunch
of stuff here but they're delaying a lot
of that so it's it's been sort of weird
to be around that but it but in a way
that actually did slightly open the door
to getting Clyde also because we
realized that our window now of where we
thought we could start this process kind
of immediately got pushed back a little
bit so we had a little more time here
and then as I said before the tour got
delayed so we had a little more time so
anyway so we're going through that
actually if any of you guys have any
insight on that or if any of you if any
of you gals have a really great egg
really great jeans and a great egg we'd
be happy to talk or if you're a
surrogate actually I guess we would talk
to you too
we've been going through all the all the
websites and trying to find you know the
right matches and you know you wanna
everyone's got got different things you
know I'm not we've sort of come around
we're not super interested in like oh
this girl
to have an Ivy League education and all
that kind of stuff like we're mostly
interested in somebody that is that is
healthy and you know hopefully you know
a little athletic and and you know you
know kind of bright and has good genes
but like I don't need like you know all
the crazy stuff that people ask for it
it doesn't have to be a freakin swimsuit
Sports Illustrated model or anything
like that so yeah I have to talk about
that publicly before so there you go
guys
but for real if you're if you've got
some eggs but you've done it before
let's talk and if you're a surrogate or
whatever else yeah so that's that so uh
but everything else truly our business
is fine right now we got this guy around
here and and I hope that in the midst of
all of this that I'm offering you guys a
little bit of a little bit of sanity in
the madness I'm gonna keep doing it and
and in the meantime and I truly truly
mean this guys if you are struggling in
any way if you lost your job
if you're having trouble paying the rent
you need food delivered to your house
whatever it might be if there's any way
that I can help you help amplify your
message or anything like that just send
an email to contact that Rubin report
calm and we'll see if we can help you as
I said this morning I tweeted out a
thing about helping people get some jobs
and somebody linked me to a groceries
chain Clyde Clyde somebody linked me to
a to a grocery chain in Jersey that's
that's mobbed right now and they're
hiring and it's like let's let's see if
we can help each other right now I
really do think we can so I'll give you
cried one more time all right dude don't
take a walk is it still raining outside
remember look at that scar he's lived
he's lived a good life anyway so as
always thanks for watching guys we're in
some weird times I'm gonna try to do
some more live streams like this we're
gonna do some with Skype video calls as
I said that was our intention today is
just to talk to you guys like I don't
want to talk to just experts right now
and celebrities and whatever else I
really do want to talk to you guys and
we just had some technical stuff today
but we'll do more of that and and I'll
continue to just try to be a
a voice of you know decency and all the
craziness and and thank you guys and I
haven't had breakfast yet so I'm gonna
go do that and stay safe everybody just
you know six feet away from people and
hope you're with somebody you love and
walk your dogs and feed your fish and
whatever else you do all right thanks